[Musica]
sono nato a napoli ho vissuto un po in
giro vissuto a parigi a londra a riad e
genero a roma
ora vivo a napoli vive lavoro a napoli e
divide il mio tempo professionale tra la
produzione artistica
dipingo con con oli graffiti ma anche
con anche forse soprattutto con la luce
dipingendo su grandi superfici su
edifici e l'altra parte del proprio
professionale invece io insegno
all'università suor orsola benincasa di
napoli retorica e storytelling digitale
il titolo di questo talk e si chiama
lighting flowers che è una installazione
su cui sto lavorando ora ma è anche un
mio modo di vivere la vita di vivere la
strada di vivere la città le
architetture di immaginare oltre il
visibile a me capita di fare questo
diciamo spesso diciamo a volte
preoccupando un po la mia compagna di
guardare i palazzi le strade i piloni
dell'autostrada il mare e la scogliera
ed immaginare dei segni di immaginare
che che ci possono essere dei segni che
delle colonne e delle donne possono
diventare rosse che si possono aprire
dei colori delle linee diciamo o questo
intervento allora vi racconterò un po
questo mio sguardo è questa produzione
del modo con cui racconto la vita
racconto quello che vedo sono tre
produzioni che corrispondono a tre
momenti importanti della mia vita
i migranti napoli le periferie
la prima installazione si chiama my
grande sirens e una installazione sulle
donne migranti donne che vengono da
dall'america latina dall'europa dell'est
dall'africa donne libere coraggiose
belle forti con una grande voglia di
fondare comunità e ea queste donne
queste zone riolo ritratte in
un'installazione nel ritratto qualche
migliaio e poi lo dipinte allora vi
faccio prima a vedere l'installazione e
poi vi racconto il senso profondo
dell'installazione è il modo con cui ho
lavorato
[Musica]
ecco queste avete visto queste alcune di
queste donne di un'installazione che poi
è stata prodotta e proiettata a
pietralcina in italia e che adesso gira
per l'europa e sono sono donne per me io
ho scelto di di leggerle in questo modo
sono donne estremamente coraggiose donne
che ha fatto una scelta di vita
profondamente difficile e la settimana
scorsa
intervistata una e le ho fatto un
ritratto e ed è un lavoro che stiamo
facendo su sulle emozioni e gli ho
chiesto di chissà quanto tempo ci è
messa viene dalla nigeria
lei mi ha detto sei mesi ha detto come
ho fatto sei mesi dalla nigeria di
trovarlo un mese per arrivare in libia e
questo non è rimasta bloccata in un
centro di detenzione per cinque mesi
allora l'ho chiesto cos'è per te la
felicità
fammi vedere un gesto di felicità e le
ha fatto così questo per noi vuol dire
tutto c'è questo per me vuol dire che
queste donne sono hanno una forza
interiore fortissima hanno forse il
motivo per cui siamo qui non parliamo di
passione hanno passione e che passione
anno alla la passione di chi vuole
fondare una nuova comunità io l'ho
chiamata e sirene di grandi perché sono
come la sirena partenope
la prima grande migrante della storia
della letteratura partenope fugge dal da
oriente arriva in un luogo che è napoli
e fonda questa città è una fondatrice
sirene migranti e il canto di un'europa
plurale vuole essere il canto di
un'europa plurale libera aperta donna
come vivono le i territori le comunità
come crescono i territori delle comunità
chris cono quando si mischiano quando si
mescolano quando le le narrazioni
interne si incontrano con le narrazioni
esterne
costruiscono nuove narrazioni ecco
sirene migranti vuole contribuire a
costruire nuove narrazioni un'altra
nuova narrazione di cui voglio parlarvi
invece axen scout e che scalza
un'installazione che ho creato sul
napoli e anche qui sono partito dalla
sirena napoli una città che offre molti
spunti una città barocca con molti
elementi museo madre mi ha chiesto di
costruire un installazione nel cortile
d'onore del museo e questa opera poi è
stata acquisita dal museo ed è diventata
un'opera che sta nella collezione
permanente ve ne parlo dopo ordine vi
faccio vedere ungiamo uno spezzone breve
un minuto in cui diciamo capirete il
senso che poi vi spiegherò dopo della
circolarità della città della
circolarità degli elementi della città
[Musica]
allora la circolarità di napoli avete
visto in questa installazione ci sono
molti elementi molte icone simboli miti
della città la sirena partenope lungo di
virgilio le capuzzelle cioè le teste di
morte che napolitano si chiama una
carrozzella san gennaro il cavallo
l'ancora io ho voluto raccontare la
ciclicità della città che vuol dire
ciclicità che napoli è una città
beh nasce con la sirena partenope non
nasce con nasce con la sirena partenope
che un simbolo per metà che un simbolo
un mostro marino per metà donna e per
metà pesce il pesce a napoli si è un
simbolo fallico e il sesso maschile
quindi diciamo l'origine della città e
per metà donna e per metà maschio
la parte di sopra e femmina la parte di
sotto è maschio la parte di sopra il
sole la parte di sotto e l'oscurità alla
parte di sopra sono le chiese in cui si
adora un dio cattolico e la parte di
sotto sono le catacombe le grotte di
tufo da cui si è scavato il tuffo per
costruire a parte di sopra e in quella
parte lì abbiamo seppellito i teschi
della peste del seicento e li abbiamo
adorato dei pagani è la città e questo è
questa eterna ciclicità di vita morte
maschile femminile cattolico pagano che
si rincorre continuamente e il senso di
questa installazione e questo diciamo ed
scalzi un opera barocca un'opera che
lavora sul sul trionfo della morte della
vita dei sensi che una cosa tipicamente
e fortemente napoletana è che io porto
dentro di me e devo dire che diciamo
permessa da importante perché lo
costruite insieme a due musicisti
straordinari che sono carola pisaturo ed
enzo avitabile che naturalmente con la
loro colonna sonora hanno contribuito a
rendere un po più forte ancora
l'emozione di questi segni sono segni
che dipingo a mano
forse l'avete visto nel video un certo
punto io mi vedete disegnare a olio e
grafite e in altri momenti invece vede
di disegni digitali o un taccuino questo
taccuino il mio diario di bordo
noi siamo un gruppo siamo una decina di
persone che lavorano con me è e come
funziona io disegno a mano
ci ho messo un anno a fare questa
l'azione quindi in un anno ho disegnato
molte cose ho preso anche appunti a
volte anche appunti mentre stava in
macchina oppure mentre era al cinema
quindi se non altro foglio di carta
quindi questo d'aquino e pieno anche di
di oggetti incollate sopra di pezzi di
termini feriti di carta di un regalo di
cose che poi ho disegnato a olio e in
grafite di appunti di bisogna fare 100
capuzzelle 60 uova di virgilio 80
cavalli c'è di elenchi e piano piano
anche di errori e di errori che ti
portano davanti ad un'altra strada ed è
un lavoro complesso e da un lavoro
complesso anche tenere insieme un equipe
che probabilmente non sa dove stiamo
andando e si preoccupa e deve capire che
deve seguirmi e naturalmente per fare
questo c'è bisogno di molta passione di
molto pathos ma c'è bisogno anche di
molto logos di molta parte razionale e
quindi molto progetto questi lavori si
fanno con una forza enorme interiore che
la passione è però dentro un framework
che un progetto e il progetto però si si
fa si disfa si rifà si disfa di nuovo e
quindi se non c'è la passione ci si
stanca l'ultima installazione di cui
voglio parlarvi e lighting flowers è un
lavoro sulle periferie io ho scelto di
dipingere di illuminare di dare la luce
a luoghi che sono in ombra che sono le
periferie di napoli di roma di milano di
parigi e rio de janeiro shanghai e tokyo
e ho cominciato adesso ne vedrete su con
due città che sono napoli e roma
possiamo vedere il video poi vi racconto
come
come viene fatto
[Musica]
per fare questo lavoro
andiamo di notte siamo diciamo
interessano io con due assistenti
abbiamo in macchina o diciamo troviamo
dei luoghi ci fermiamo e sono lui che
abbiamo scelto prima ci fermiamo io un
gruppo elettrogeno poi c'è un cavalletto
con il proiettore e poi ci sono due
computer e poi gli assistenti hanno un
drone una steady cam e due telecamere
fisse per documentare tutto e sono
lavori di notte sono lavori che si fanno
senza permessi quindi diciamo un po
rischiosi perché naturalmente alle 3 del
mattino in periferia è un po più più
rischioso però vi racconto un aneddoto
che per me è la chiave di tutto forse
anche la chiave di perché faccio certe
cose perché mi piacciono cosa mi
entusiasma erano le tre e mezza della
mattina eravamo a gianturco periferia
orientale di napoli
stavamo illuminando il ponte della
circumvesuviana un certo punto una
macchina si ferma e c'erano un uomo una
donna e una bambina con dei grandi
occhialoni e che rimarrà per tutto il
tempo in silenzio la signora abbassa il
finestrino e mi diceva stai facendo una
fotografica dicono signora di rosso
riprendendo sto facendo la ripresa alla
golosità juliis come stai facendo una
fotografia di conoscerò guardi veramente
sto facendo le riprese alla sera apre lo
sportello e mi si butta addosso aveva
pasquale la ferma e dice signore signore
ad istituire un artista guardi stiamo
facendo
un'installazione atto dimostra la cosa
lei si gira e dice genna scilla rama a
gina esce gennaro dalla macchina un
umane gigantesco testa con loculo un
unico blocco di cemento
naturalmente eravamo tutti molto
preoccupati
gennaro dice che ricuce 8 e concetta
vice el'arte
gennaro si avvicina a me mette la mano
nella giacca di 5 giu io pensavo è
finita questo chiaramente mi lascerà per
terra caccia un cellulare melo che dice
faccina fotografici si abbraccia
concetta e io naturalmente con una mano
tremante
gli faccio la foto e poi dopo loro vanno
via e ho pensato a parte ha pensato ce
l'abbiamo fatta
ma a parte questi ho pensato però sono
fatta davvero ci sono riuscito
forse sono riuscito a comunicare l'arte
rustu povero la meraviglia la bellezza
in un posto dove di notte non c'è nulla
a due persone che alle tre e mezza del
mattino sono in una tale da una tale
dose di paranoia addosso che sono
convinti che gli sto facendo una
fotografia che stola per loro si usano è
riuscito a emozionare queste due persone
e allora forse ho raggiunto l'obiettivo
però poi nei giorni seguenti ho pensato
che forse era successo anche
qualcos'altro forse ho sperato ho
pensato ho sognato che forse quella
bambina che rimasta per tutto il tempo
in silenzio e che era terrorizzata
perché aveva un papa una mamma un po
particolari
forse in quel tempo avrà visto che era
possibile di notte in una periferia in
un post oscuro non posso dove c'è solo
ombra disagio miseria deserto totale c'è
un pazzo che fa delle luci e che crea
degli effetti dei colori delle pitture
allora ho pensato che forse questa
bambina da grande potrebbe decidere
anche lei di fare queste cose anche lei
di contribuire a mettere luce nel mondo
e allora diciamo le storie che vi ho
raccontato sono tutte sono tutte storie
di passione di mutazione di
trasformazioni sono storie di fiori
luminosi sono storie del mio desiderio
di piantare fiori luminosi nel mondo
grazie
[Musica]